okay welcome to the show everybody good
to see you again this is my my last show
my last show ever I'm retiring I wish I
wish that was true my last show of the
week actually is what it is because I'm
going into surgery tomorrow for the torn
Akili situation which I've been
complaining about for you know for for
the last week and then they tell me that
I'll be bedridden I'll be bedridden and
and hopped up on painkillers for a
couple of days which you know I thought
that maybe I could still do the show
laying in bed on oxy cotton but it
that'd be very interesting anyway but I
thought maybe at the end of the day it's
probably not the wisest decision okay I
want to pause for a minute to tell you
about genu cell you know double chins
sagging jaw lines turkey necks they are
real problems and difficult to deal with
if you have it but you don't have to
worry about it anymore introducing the
new genu cell jawline treatment
formulated with MDL technology and
gemüse genja cells amazing Mother's Day
sale if you happen to miss it the good
news is that it's been extended for a
limited time Robin s from Lubbock Texas
wrote in with her testimonial says I put
that jawline cream my neck like two or
three days ago that is the best my neck
has looked at over 20 years several
people told me my face looks young I am
blown away sure you could you know you
could experiment with all the expensive
and harsh treatments to look younger but
why would you do that when you've got
this option instead for a limited time
get the genu cell jawline treatment
absolutely free when you order the
classic Jen you sell for eye bags and
puffiness and with it's instant effects
you could see results in the first 12
hours guaranteed or you get your money
back so there's no risk here go to Jen
you sell calm that's Jen you sell calm
and enter Matt twenty five at checkout
for my special discount visit Jen you
sell calm that's Jen you sell calm enter
Matt twenty five at checkout alright
let's begin with with something that I
think's a problem in this country which
is that people don't understand
Christianity there's a that's a common
theme these days right we've and we've
got a few examples of that today we'll
start with this president Trump stopped
by MacLaine Bible Church in Virginia
over the weekend to pray with the
congregation
in the wake of the terrible shooting
that happened in Virginia Beach a
shooting that by the way it's it seemed
it seems like it just I don't know we're
at the point now where you have a mass
shooting 11 people are killed and
everyone moves on in like a day I mean
you think back to Columbine where it was
I think it was 13 people I believe were
killed in Columbine and and that was the
only thing people talked about for two
months
it was biggest story in the world and
now we're at a point where we just move
on in a day from it and I think that's
that's not a good sign
but president Trump showed up at the
church to pray with the congregation and
the Pastor David plant while the
president was in attendance offered a
short prayer for the president
I thought the prayer was was beautiful
is very well done not political at all
nothing partisan about it just a
biblically sound prayer for a man in a
position of leadership here's a play a
little bit of the prayers with the
prayer sounded like so I want to ask us
to bow our heads together now and pray
for our president
Oh God we praise you as one universal
King overall you are our leader and our
Lord and we worship you there's one God
and one Savior and it's you and your
name is Jesus and we exalt you Jesus
we know we need your mercy
we need your grace we need your help we
need your wisdom in our country and so
we stand right now on behalf of our
president and we pray for your grace and
your mercy and your wisdom upon him god
we pray that he would know how much you
love him
so much that you sent Jesus to die for
his sins our sins so we pray that he
would look to you and he would trust in
you that he would lean on you that he
would govern and make decisions in ways
that are good for justice and good for
righteousness and good for equity every
good path ok so that's good stuff right
well apparently not at least not in the
minds of people who were offended by the
fact that the pastor prayed for Trump in
fact people were so hurt by this fact
that that Platt had to issue a lengthy
statement defending his decision to pray
for the president it wasn't an apology
I've seen some news reports about it
saying pastor apologizes for praying for
truck he didn't apologize for it but he
did explain why he did it and I think
that's that's a bad enough that's a bad
sign right there when a pastor has to
explain to his own congregation why he
offered a prayer for the president who
was in attendance at the church it's now
controversial apparently for a Christian
pastor to pray for the president of
course anyone who has even the faintest
understanding of Christianity would not
be scandalized by those Christians pray
for everybody Christians are supposed to
pray for everybody pray for your friends
or foes your neighbors or strangers
victims criminals murderers everyone I
mean you're supposed to pray for
everyone it's very clear especially our
political leaders the Bible specifically
commands us to pray for our leaders so
this again just shows how although
America is nominally a Christian nation
and most people supposedly are Christian
or are at least self professed
Christians still Christianity is little
understood in this country let's look at
it another example perhaps a more
dramatic example on Saturday a bishop
from Rhode Island Bishop Thomas Tobin
sent out a tweet that has sparked
backlash and you know it's bad when it
sparks backlash it's got to be bad
because I mean there are
only a thousand different backlashes
that happen every day so you know it's
not like people are having bats it's not
like we have backlashes over stupid
things right we choose our backlashes
very carefully which we specifically
choose a thousand different ones every
day
we're very discerning about it so but
this is a major this is a worldwide
controversy now people getting very
upset here's what the tweet said from
Bishop Tobin said a reminder that
Catholics should not support or attend
LGBTQ Pride Month events held in June
they promote a culture and encourage
activities that are contrary to Catholic
faith and morals they are especially
harmful to children okay now you may not
agree with that a lot of people don't
obviously but how could anyone be
shocked that's what I don't get see this
is where it shows people don't
understand Christianity that you have
all these people that are shocked by the
statement scandalized they can't believe
that anyone would come out and say
somebody STUV all a bishop the Catholic
Church has always been opposed to pride
parades always why at least when I say
always as long as pride parades have
been a thing the Catholic Church has
been opposed it why is that because
according to the Bible marriage is
between a man and a woman and sex is
meant to be kept within marriage that is
the biblical understanding that's the
Catholic understanding that's the
Christian understanding this is standard
Christian teaching as such of course an
observant Christian will not be in favor
of events that celebrate something which
they believe to be sinful and this is
not just about gay people by the way I
you know I'm guessing that if you asked
Bishop Tobin how he feels about say you
know these debauched spring break you
know events Spring Break which has
become a celebration of debauchery among
among heterosexuals and and almost
was to that attend I'm guessing if you
asked him how he thought about that
about you know a bunch of college kids
going down to you know go into the beach
somewhere
Cancun or whatever and engaging in all
these kinds of activity I'm guessing
that if you asked him I thought about it
he would say that he's against it I'm
guessing he would tell you that he
doesn't like it because it's a
celebration of and an opportunity to
participate in sexually immoral behavior
not specifically gay behaviors also
heterosexual behavior but the point is
from the perspective of the bishop and
from any devout Catholic is that this is
behavior that ought to be within kept
within marriage biblical marriage I'm
guessing you that I'm guessing that he
would also tell you that he's against
explicit TV shows like Game of Thrones
which depict and glorify immoral
sexuality I'm guessing that if you asked
him how he feels about a heterosexual
couple living together before marriage
he would tell you that he's against it
and if there was some weird kind of
event or a bunch of cohabitating
heterosexual couples got together and
had a parade to set to to talk about how
proud they are of living together before
marriage I'm guessing that Bishop Tobin
would be against that and he would say
no that shouldn't be happening and you
shouldn't participate if you're a
Catholic the point is that he's being
consistent he's a Catholic bishop and
he's being consistent with Catholic
teaching he is expressing a biblically
coherent and consistent point of view
and one that does not simply target
homosexuals it is a view that is
centered around an idea of chastity and
moded a modesty again you're free to
disagree but what is there to be
surprised by how could you be outraged
by it you already unless your total
idiot you know that this is how the
Catholic Church this is what the
Catholic Church is teaching his you must
know that by now
so how could you be offended if someone
who represents the
the church comes out and says their
point of view on the subject it's it's
so it's so silly it's just so ridiculous
one other point here you know you can't
march through the streets literally
announcing your sexuality to the world
you can't constantly shove it in front
of people's faces you can't insist that
we all look and acknowledge your
sexuality and then get offended when
someone offers an opinion about it you
brought it up if you don't want people
talking about it then don't bring it up
if you don't want to know if you don't
want Bishop Tobin's opinion on your
sexuality then why are you marching
through the street announcing it so this
is this is kind of how the conversation
goes the LGB camp you know the LGBTQ
camp will say hey everyone look at us
look at us everyone look look look at us
please look at us we're marching through
the street look look at us this is what
let us tell you about our sexuality I
know you didn't ask but we're going to
tell you look at us please please we're
proud we're proud and then someone says
okay well here's my opinion about that
how dare you give us your opinion this
is none of your business
well if it's none of our business why
are you talking about it why are you
literally marching in the street
announcing it if it's none of our
business so you can't do that you can't
have it both ways
you can do it you can march in the
street you're free to do that in America
but you can't have it both ways okay you
can't shove this unwanted information in
my face and then tell me that I'm that
I'm supposed to respond to it
it doesn't work that way because this is
America so America in America you have
the right to market to march through the
street and tell everybody about your sex
life if you want to I don't know why you
want to I I have no interest in doing
that
but you can do that but you don't get to
set the rules for the conversation okay
you can't bring it up to me and then
tell me how I'm supposed to respond
hours
but however I damn well please if you
don't want to hear my opinion don't
bring it up now here you know that goes
for any topic literally any topic any
topic you bring up to me I am well
within my rights stick offer my opinion
on
I mean I'm within my rights tall for my
opinion even if you don't bring it up
but especially if you do if you don't
care about my perspective they don't
tell me about it there are a lot of
things there are a lot of details about
my life my personal life that of which I
don't care you know that I don't care
what your opinion is about those things
now I tend to keep my private life
private and the reason why I keep it
private is that the things that are
private to me it's just it's it's none
of your business and I don't care what
your opinion is about it I don't care
what your perspective is about it you
know things about my family you know how
my family works and and and and all of
it I don't care what your opinion is I
don't care what your perspective is no
offense to you that's why I don't bring
out so I don't talk about it anything
about my life that I put out there in
the open for general consumption I must
be putting it out there because at some
level I do care about your perspective
now I might hope that you have one
particular perspective you know I might
put it out there because I'm hoping that
you'll have an affirming a proving
perspective but I don't get to decide
that that's a risk I take if I put it
out there and and and you have a
negative perspective well that's your
that's that's just the way it goes let's
take an example my faith for example
okay now my
viii is a is a is a private detail about
my life in a sense you know it's it's a
it's a it's a detail about my personal
life about me my faith yet I do talk
about it openly I do put it out there
the number one because I feel that as
Christians were called to do that that
we're not supposed to just keep it
private but I do put it out there not
because I want you to affirm it or to
tell me it's okay to be Christian but I
do want to tell you about it and I know
that when I do that I open myself up for
criticism because I might tell you about
my faith and you might not agree with my
faith so you might have criticisms you
might argue against it I can't I can't
start crying about it when you do that
if I tell you here's my faith here's
what I believe and you say here's what I
believe about what you believe I can't
say well how dare you you're offending
me how dare you tell me that I brought
it up and the thing is for me when I
bring up my faith and you come with your
with your contrary opinions I'm excited
to have that conversation I'm more than
willing to have that conversation I I
would love to have that debate with you
so I just can't conceive of talking
about something of bringing something up
about my life that I don't want to talk
about your talking about something you
don't want to talk about that doesn't
make sense so if you really think it's
it's none of anyone's business then just
don't don't bring it up by the way one
other thing here bishop Tobin in that
tweet I just read he said that pride
events harm children you know and and
that's something that is especially
offended a lot of people well yeah I
mean I can't imagine why he would say
that right it's so offensive oh maybe he
said that because of this
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah the headline of that video is a
seven-year-old trans child wins la Pride
Parade with fierce strut in heels so
you've got you've got a seven-year-old
boy strutting according to this headline
in in high heels and a dress and and
he's at the at the head of the of the
Pride Parade yeah maybe that's why
Bishop Tobin observed that these events
can be harmful to children because what
you're seeing there what you just saw in
that clip that is the sexual abuse of a
child to put a seven-year-old boy in a
dress and high heels and have him strut
that is abusive it is the it is the
sexual ization of a child and it is
abusive and so I would call that sexual
abuse of a child you know what I would
say that if he was a girl I mean to have
a why do they even make high heels that
a seven-year-old can fit in if it was a
seven year old girl strutting in high
heels I would say that's incredibly
inappropriate and gross and wrong the
fact that it's a boy makes it even more
demented and just deranged so what kind
of message do you think you're sending
if you if you don't want people to think
that pride parades are harmful to
children then maybe don't put a
seven-year-old boy to dress and high
heels and have him strutting in front of
the parade what the hell do you think
people are gonna think well it's not
about what they think they're just going
to observe that okay well this event in
it anyway is sexualizing a
seven-year-old boy but at la Pride
Parade the people that put that out
there the ones who chose to do that you
can't get mad at Bishop Tobin for
pointing it out you can't get mad at me
for pointing it out all right now let's
check in with our friends at dynamic
solutions you know it's it's summertime
and the only thing more annoying than
all the politics in the news
right now is flies and other insects
which invade your home and just make
life pretty miserable and and you know
the thing about flies is who knows where
they've where they've been you see them
landing on your hamburger or your
sandwich last place they were probably a
dumpster or trash can so you don't want
those disgusting infernal creatures
flying around your home which is why
we'd like to thank our sponsors over at
dynatrap dynatrap is the leading
manufacturer of outdoor mosquito and
insect traps and now they've come up
with a solution for indoor pests as well
that's the dynatrap fly light the
dynatrap fly light works day and night
to attract and trap flies fruit flies
mosquitoes any other pesky insect that
might fly around your house and I got to
tell you it really does work I've got
I've got the folks at dynatrap are nice
enough to send me a bunch I've got them
all around the house and we have not had
any fly problems any mosquito problems
we can leave the windows open and it's
not a problem and you know we don't
worry about those disgusting fly strips
either because the dynatrap fly light
looks like a like a nightlight that's
plugged into your your outlet but it
also does much more than a nightlight
does trust me I've been using the
dynatrap fly light for a couple days now
and it's just it's insane how many
insects these things catch so get yours
at dynatrap comm that's D Y and a TR ap
comm enter the promo code Walsh and
receive 15% off any of their products
dynatrap the safe silent and simple
solution to household insect control all
right uh let's see one other thing Texas
the state of Texas continues to be in my
mind the best state in the Union and I
continue to be jealous very jealous of
everyone who lives there because I I
don't live there myself and I think
Texas has everything going for it
culturally and legally and so many other
aspects except the weather is just not
the weather and the bugs the one problem
if you could take Texas and just kind of
like pick just carve the whole state out
and pick it up and transport it by
helicopter maybe 500
north and you know you could just plop
it on top of some other states no big
deal then I think it'd be the perfect
state but anyway Texas continues to uh
continues to impress Greg Abbott the
governor posted this video over the
weekend watch this hi governor Greg
Abbott here at the Capitol on Saturday
signing bills I'm about to sign this
bill that bans red-light cameras in
Texas is now law all right so he's
banning red-light cameras and why did he
ban red-light cameras well because
red-light cameras are a money-making
scam and nothing more that's all they
are there's no there's no safe public
safety angle to it it is just about
making money as Publix it's a
money-making operation they profit off
of traffic infractions but do not
prevent them and there have been a lot
of studies on that that have shown this
there's an article on motorist org you
can go to that website and check it out
which cites a bunch of studies too many
to list but like I said you can go and
look at it yourself all of these studies
showing that red-light cameras actually
increase accidents and certainly don't
decrease or prevent them and it's not
hard to see why that would be the case
because people end up end up speeding
faster through the intersection if they
know there's a red-light camera because
they don't want to be caught by that's
what ends up happening I know I've done
this myself where you know I've had
times where I'm coming up to an
intersection and and it goes yellow
right at that you know there's that
there's that window of about I don't
know ten or ten feet or so where it's an
awkward window or if the if the light
goes yellow in that moment your eyes are
gonna have to slam on your brakes or
speed up to try to get through the
intersection and then you have to kind
of choose which one and sometimes it
could be safer to speed up depending on
how close the car is behind you so now
if if I know that there's a red light
camera at that
section I'm probably more likely to
speed up and try to go through it
because I know that if I try to stop for
it but I end up over the line a little
bit I could get ticketed and so I think
that's one of the reasons why these
things just create more accidents and
maybe that's the wrong choice but the
point remains one way or another that
red-light cameras don't make anyone
safer they just don't and the stats
speak for themselves so why have them
what's the point if you've got all of
these studies that have been done over
the years and they so many of them
demonstrate seemingly conclusively that
red-light cameras don't prevent
accidents or prevent these traffic
infractions why keep doing them because
it allows the state to profit from law
breaking which creates a conflict of
interest because now the state actually
wants people to run the light because
they make money from it you know these
states become dependent on speeding
tickets and red-light tickets they fund
things with these tickets so they need
you to keep on doing it so they can make
money from it
in fact there have been cities that have
actually shortened the yellow light time
they there's this happen in many cities
where they put the red light cameras in
and then what do you know magically all
the sudden the the yellow lights are
shorter and why do they do that because
they want you to run it now it's very
clear that longer yellow lights are
safer because they give more people more
time to prepare to stop or to go through
the intersection if they're close enough
you shorten the yellow light time and
you're more likely to catch people in
the middle of the intersection on a red
light they do that anyway even though
it's dangerous because it means they
make more money and they want people to
run it it's the same thing with speeding
have you ever been you know where I live
there are a lot of roads like this it's
very frustrating but have you ever been
on one of those roads usually it's a
back road country road type of thing
where the speed limit changes randomly
back and forth from 50 to 35 back to 50
to 45 to 30 25 20 50 you know you're
going and the speed limit changes five
times in a span
ten miles and why is that because they
want you to speed and what you're gonna
find is that so often you know when the
speed limit goes from 50 to 35 and then
back up to 50 and 35 again at one of
those changes there's gonna be a cop a
lot of times hidden out there just
waiting waiting for you to waiting to
catch you right so they can make some
money it's it's the the thing that's
terrible about is all of this traffic
enforcement stuff which is not really
enforcement but again it's just making
money but it has I think fundamentally
change the nature and purpose of law
enforcement because we've turned police
officers into tax collectors and into
bill collectors revenue generators or
not even generators but but
appropriators and so we have them camped
out on the side of the road waiting for
an opportunity to collect rather than
out actually fighting crime and looking
for real dangerous crime that they can
stop and then the red-light camera thing
just takes that mentality to the next
level where it says okay well why do we
even need the police officer and so it
cut outs cuts out the middleman and
instead if you run the red light it
snaps a picture sends you a bill to your
house says oh you ran a red light so you
owe the state $75
well why though what even is the
correlation why should a minor traffic
infraction mean that the state gets
money I don't even see the correlation
there it doesn't make sense and the
whole picture just solidifies the
impression that people have that the
state is this opportunistic
money-grubbing entity that's hiding
around every corner waiting for you to
trip up so that they can reach into your
wallet and take some of your money and
that is not the relationship that a
citizen should have with his government
in a free country but that's just not it
so I'm a big fan of getting rid of the
red light cameras they really are in you
know it's talking about this a few days
ago it's shocking to me that there are
actually there are actually people
regular citizens
who are in favor of red-light cameras
you know makes me think of that quote
from the the no bow down and and and
licked the chains that bind you or
something like I'm mangling the quote
but that's that's what people have come
have fallen in love with their chains I
guess that they they actually are in
favor of red liking you again the
red-light cameras they're not there to
make you safer they are just there to
make money off of you that's the only
reason that they're there the state puts
them in there because they want you to
break the law so they can make money off
of you doing it how could you possibly
be in favor of that I just I I don't
understand so I want to take a second to
tell you about wise company freeze-dried
food listen you never know when you're
gonna be in an emergency situation and
think about an emergency is that you
don't have time to prepare for it while
it's happening that's why it's preparing
means ahead of time you've got to be
ready for it
which is why it's so great that wise
company freeze-dried food is good for
twenty five years so you get twenty five
years of preparation with with wise
company which is remarkable wise company
takes an innovative approach and
providing dependable simple and
affordable freeze-dried food for
emergency preparedness and outdoor use
and you get a lot with that but I think
the number one thing you get is peace of
mind when government resources are
strained it can be days if not weeks
before you can get fresh food and water
so you can't rely on someone else you
got to take care of yourself this week
my listeners get any wise company
emergency or outdoor food product and an
extra twenty five percent off the lowest
mark price at wise food storage calm
that's wise food storage calm if you
enter Walsh at checkout or you can call
eight five five four seven five three
zero eight nine plus to make it even
better shipping is free
wise has a ninety day no question to ask
return policy so there's no risk and
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family more prepared today
that's wise food storage calm promo code
Walsh to get any wise emergency or
outdoor food product at an extra twenty
five percent off
also free shipping all right Matt Walsh
Oh at gmail.com
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com let's check
some emails this is from norm says Walsh
the bearded I think I found a perfect
word to describe anyone who was
attracted to anything all sexual you're
welcome
PS please don't execute me when you gain
power in the foreseeable future well
norm you think you know I can't make
that promise on the last point on the
first one yeah I think it's pretty good
all sexual you know we talked about
yesterday that we've got a set we got a
word for it we've a sexual so those are
people who aren't attracted to anything
and then there's what was a gray sexual
are people who are just attracted to
some things which is pretty much
everybody and then I said well what
about someone who's attracted to ever
who is sexually attracted to literally
everything in existence now I don't
think that such a person exists but that
hasn't stopped us from creating labels
and in the past I mean just because the
person doesn't exist doesn't mean we
can't have a label for it so I think we
need a label for that just to complete
the spectrum and all sexual I could go
with that yeah we'll do that all sexual
all right from Megan says hey Matt just
wanted to get your opinion on the ethics
behind bodies the the exhibition this is
a hugely popular exhibit that's been
around since 2007 these exhibits display
human corpses that have been preserved
and solidified through plastination and
outer layers are peeled back to reveal
their organs or joints or muscles and
the corpses some of the corpses are
posed to show movement as if they are
dancing playing sports or doing yoga and
others give a visual for various disease
states copying this right off their
website this is their reasoning for
using real bodies says unlike models
that idealize the body through the eyes
of an artist the specimens in the
exhibition display the body and its
parts as they really exist idealized
models have been used for many years to
teach anatomy however models do not
allow for any variation in structure of
pathologies which is key and learning
how life style and disease actually
manifests inside the human body says I
am less bothered by the idea people in
the u.s. following Streak strict legal
and profusely documented means of Dodi
their body after they die to be used
solely by medical professional schools
to be studied and then returned to
families for final burial however I
think that this crosses the line as
these exhibits are profiting immensely
from displaying of the corpses of others
in the name of education another big
issue is that according to their website
there are using bodies from China that
were unclaimed and therefore
automatically donated to pet to medical
school / Chinese law hi Megan yeah it's
it's a that's a great topic I in in my
younger and less discerning days I did
attend one of those exhibits there was
one in Philadelphia I believe it was and
I think was 18 or 19 and I went to one
of them it was it was bizarre and weird
and gross and just something I wish I
hadn't been a part of I do think it's
morally problematic to put dead bodies
on display like like like art show
exhibits I think we need to uphold the
dignity of the human person before
before death and after death dead body
should be treated with respect
organ donation is one thing to give your
body up to another person you know so
that they can continue living I think
it's a beautiful thing but to give your
body as a freak show exhibit for
tourists to walk around and gawk at I I
just I don't see that as noble or or
dignified or or anything like that so
now you could claim as they do
apparently that the that the exhibit is
educational and I guess it is sort of
but whatever educating they do they
could do it just as easily with with
without actual dead bodies they could
come up with anatomical models that are
not idealized that are more realistic if
they really want to and I do think it's
different if you of course donating an
organ is one thing and also donating a
body being donated to a medical school I
would agree with you that's different as
well but people who go to a museum
exhibit are not at medical school and
they're not necessarily future doctors
okay they don't need an exact rendering
of what a dead body looks like for
whatever you're trying to accomplish
with the exhibit for the most
as I said I went to one of them I know
that people are there it's it's it's
it's it's a these are tourists like I
said that come here it's not people
aren't there with lab coats and and
clipboards taking notes and everything
like that that's not it's people go
there to gawk at the exhibit that's the
primary function and so I think
displaying a dead body for that purpose
is is grotesque all right um this is
from mark says I have stumbled upon this
question while debating Pro abortionists
why is it wrong and illegal for my wife
to to drink or do a lot of hard drugs
while pregnant
according to then it is her body and she
could do whatever she wants with it so
why can't she do those hard drugs is
addicting her children to drugs now call
worse than actually killing them I never
had a pro-choice or making cohesive
argument to this question or any
question regarding abortion actually
they all think it's wrong but they don't
know why yeah mark well that's just one
of dozens of areas where the pro-choice
the pro-choice in quotes pro-abortion
position is incoherent because you're
you you will very rarely stumble across
a pro-abortion person who would be
totally cool with a pregnant woman you
know doing cocaine and and chugging six
beers right you're gonna very rarely
come across someone like that yet
according to them it's her bodies you
can do with the one not only is it her
body but the child doesn't exist yet
that thing in the womb is not a child
not a person not a human so who cares
obviously there's an inconsistency there
but don't expect to hear a coherent
argument dealing with that because there
isn't one
this is from David says Matt as someone
with a degree in applied mathematics I'd
like to help clarify an issue you
briefly mentioned last week when it
comes to quantifying victimhood status
the following rules applied everyone
starts from a bit from a base of zero
you can be a victim and oppressor
neither or both but you can't be
negative in either category each claim
to victimhood comes with a both both a
base point value and a multiplication
factor for example being black grants
you 100 victim points but also gives you
a multiplier of 1.5 so if you're only
claimed a victimhood as being black you
have 150 total victim points
multiplication factors are compounding
to continue the example being female is
worth 150 points and carries a
multiplier of 1.75 so a black female has
250 base points times 1 point 5 for
being black times 1.75 for being female
for a total of 650 6.25 victim points
using these rules and criteria you
mentioned last week we can make the
following evaluation temporary physical
disability is worth 50 points and
carries a multiplier of 1 potential for
surgical complications is unfortunately
worth no points but carries a multiplier
of 1 1 being an undetermined being an
undetermined part Native American
carries 75 points so that's pretty good
with a multiplier of 1.25 being part
Irish is worth 25 points and carries a
multiplier of 1 so I'm doing pretty well
here being part of trillion carries no
points in a multiplier of 1 in other
words no effect unfortunately being
straight white male and Christian are
all worth zero points and I'm afraid
each carries a multiplier of 0.1 so your
total is 50 plus 75 plus 25 times one
times one point one times 1.25 times one
times one times point zero one times
point zero one times point zero one
times point zero one equals point zero
two zero six two five victim points when
compared with the theoretical maximum
score of 50,000 points for physically
and mentally handicapped gay transgender
Black Muslim female making 30 cents on
the dollar doing the same work as a man
you can see that your score pales in
comparison of course the major problem
with the calculation of victimhood is
that point values
arbitrary and subject to change based on
current events Democratic talking points
which college which college campus
you're currently on etc but I hope this
helps clarify things to the extent that
any leftist idea can be clarified yeah
okay that was way too much math for me
so you've confused me there but what i
zero didn't on here is that you say that
i have point zero two zero six two five
victim points so what you're saying is
that i am a victim
so you're saying i'm a victim is what
you're saying that's all I really wanted
to establish and I would also now I
think that your calculation is for the
most part pretty solid you did make a
few mistakes here for instance you said
that that being black grants you one
hundred victim points being a female
grants you 150 points well you're wrong
I would switch that around whereas being
a racial minority is worth more victim
points certainly than being a female
because if you're a white straight
heterosexual female you are you know you
are a victim and you're certainly higher
on the totem pole than a white male but
you're you can only the white male is
right below you right so you're out
there's only one you are one level up as
a white heterosexual female so that's
how it goes you know you have white
males then white females and then you
start and then you get into the racial
minorities and if but of course I would
agree with you and I think it's
important how you factored in that now
if you are a female racial minority then
that's gonna be worth extra and you're
gonna rank above a male racial minority
so that's the way it goes remember
basically females are always above males
in each kind of subcategory until you
get to the very top where you have quote
unquote transgender women who are at the
very top who are the most victimized but
of course they are not female they're
male so anyway very interesting
discussion and I think that someone
needs to do a paper on this
put it in a science scientific journal
of some kind just to really quantify all
the victim points and everything so I
appreciate that David and we will leave
it there I will talk to you next week
hopefully by then I will have an intact
Achilles and have a great week great
weekend Godspeed sex cells sex Rob's -
we will examine the difference between a
casual hookup and assault and robbery
then in the NBA players want to get rid
of the term owner because apparently
everything is racist now we'll explain
how when everything is racist nothing is
racist and finally President Trump goes
to the motherland check it out on the
Michael Noel's show